Welcome to English in a minute.
The beach is such a fun place.
You can swim in the ocean and dig in the sand.
You can even bury things in the sand.
But I wouldn't recommend doing this.
Bury your head in the sand.
Jonathan, what are you doing about the plankton problem?
Plankton problem?
I don't know about any plankton problem.
I feel like the whole world is burying its head in the sand...
...about the plankton problem.
I'm not avoiding the plankton problem.
I know nothing about the plankton problem.
To bury your head in the sand...
...means to hide from a problem or unpleasant reality.
But at some point,...
...you will have to face whatever situation you are avoiding.